and we now move to the next topic that
once again seemingly has nothing to do
with this sequence comparison we are now
on a sightseeing tour in Manhattan and
our goal is to walk from the
intersection shown in blue to the
intersection shown in red and to visit
as many attractions as possible the only
restriction is that we can either move
south or east what should be our
strategy to visit the maximum number of
attraction on this trip we can model
Manhattan as grid and show edges in this
grid where the retractions as edges of
weight one and then our goal is to find
a path in this graph that has maximum
number of attractions sometimes computer
scientists call longest path in this
graph from the blue node to the red node
we can actually try to solve this
problem in an arbitrary grip with this
arbitrary number of attractions like
this grid shown here there are many
different ways to travel in this grid
for example we can travel like this and
in this case we will visit 18
attractions the length of the longest
path is 18 is that an optimal path no
because we can travel differently and in
this case visit to Munich attraction
what should be our strategy for the
optimum exploration of Manhattan we need
to solve the Manhattan tourist problem
the input is a weighted rectangular grid
and the output longest path from the
source vertex the vertex shown by blue
to the synchro Arctic the Arctic shown
by red in this grid so what should we do
the simplest things that come to mind is
to explore a greedy strategy for example
there in the very beginning we can
either move
or move south if we move with we will
visit three attraction immediately if we
move south we'll visit only one it makes
sense to move east let's do it
then afterwards once again we can move
assist ourselves we make choice based on
the more maximum number attraction and
we continually exist and finally we
arrive to the source visiting monastry
attractions and you have already guessed
that this is a very simple strategy but
not optimal what we need now to find the
optimal strategy another thing we need
to keep in mind is that Manhattan is not
a perfect rectangle grid Broadway cuts
across and we can model this grid as an
arbitrary graph where edges can go from
whatever the Arctic's would ever know to
whatever node and how do we travel in
this grid and to travel in this rate we
need to solve longest paths in a
directed graph problem where input is an
edge weighted directed graph with the
source and sync node and output is
simply a longest path from source to
sank in this graph now you may be
surprised by now why I am talking about
alignment game and Manhattan
do you see connection between the
longest path problem and the alignment
game and it may not have this that there
is a connection but let's try to figure
out what is it
let's for every call of the alignment
matrix let's code it with an arrow as I
showed in this slide and then after we
design this arrow let's see how this
arrow would translate into the new grid
that I have constructed and presented in
this slide the first arrow is diagonal
let's move diagonally in our grid the
next error is also diagonal let's move
diagonally again the next arrow is
horizontal we continue further
horizontally diagonal diagonal vertical
diagonal vertical diagonal and
actually using climent matrix we were
able to travel in Manhattan grade right
now let's ask reverse question if we
have a path in Manhattan grid would we
be able to construct the alignment
matrix let's try this is an arbitrary
pass in the alignment grid let's combine
all the arrows in one place and as soon
as we've done it of course we can
construct the alignment matrix as I
showed here there are four alignment and
nothing but passes in the grid and
therefore to place the alignment game to
construct longest comments isoquant is
the only thing we need to do is to
travel optimal ways in the graph and the
question often for sequence comparison
problem in biology amounts to billion in
appropriate Manhattan will do it lot in
this lecture in the case of longest
common subsequence so what would be this
Manhattan in this case diagonal right
edges correspond to matching symbol and
have score 1 if this corresponding
symbols for this diagonal edges match to
each other and high-scoring climent in
this case is simply longest path in a
properly built Manhattan and to learn
how we travel in whatever Manhattan we
need once again to talk about the
problem that seemingly has nothing to do
with biology and it is the change
problem
you